[Musique]
je
nous avons regardé ce message de très
près et débattu des manifestations qui
se tiennent dans le minnesota afin
d'évaluer si ce message transgresser
notre charte ou non même si ce message
contenait des références historiques
troublante
nous avons décidé de ne pas le supprimer
car nous l'avons considéré comme un
avertissement concernant l'action de
l'état et nous pensons que les gens
doivent savoir si le gouvernement est
prêt à employer à force
une
[Musique]
le
je ne sais pas quoi faire mais je sais
que ne rien faire n'est pas acceptable
je suis un employé de facebook en
désaccord complet avec la décision de
marc de ne rien faire au sujet des
messages récents de trump qui incite
clairement à la violence marc à tort et
je vais m'efforcer de le faire changer
d'avis en faisant beaucoup de bruit
je pense que le tweet de trump sur les
pillages encouragent la violence
extrajudiciaires et attise le racisme
respect l'équipe de twitter ne rien
faire n'est pas faire preuve d'audace
c'est ce que ressentent beaucoup d'entre
nous
[Musique]